hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen on just see I'm Jonathan oh
hi and we're festive today for the July
4th holiday it goes with local Martha
who say we're gonna make this cake it's
a one two three four is a five layer
cake it's also got so this is what we're
gonna make know what's gonna happen I
still can't figure out how that's gonna
happen well we cut out the middle so we
kind of cheated I already bought a blue
cake a partially red cake and this white
cake so we're just gonna kind of see
what happens I think I might have baked
my phone inside of this whole back my
shirt is missing the covers okay let me
show you my spine cover it this is
America okay
first things first we're gonna make one
of our case why should we make all the
cakes at the same time oh let's do them
all the same time I'm somewhat about
that majoring life god I was a fool for
okay so it's not gonna fit in there Oh
[Music]
that's a lot really
oh no I mean it why it's not yellow
shoots but perfect I am a professional
good for you just rubbing it oh no a
little bit yellow a lot hmm okay one
third all right so now it's time to
blend our first one up here we go
jail of America yeah mmm cake she need
help oh it's really pretty
America it smells like blueberry it kind
of actually smells like underwear one
direction I was like blueberry like gym
underwear I've never I don't wear out of
her I made a real big mess you spread my
phone 350 years old um
really oh sorry looks like a solid line
in Japan really I don't know I think 28
to 31
wait there's let me look on the trash
faith it's all done like I could have
told you that what's just within me oh
all right so once I put the cakes in the
oven actually directions say only one
cake but now what content burn all the
cakes in let's wrap those little board
do put them all in the same emergency
whoa did you take a spoonful of cake
batter
I'm trying to freaking prepare oh my god
case you're wondering what this might
look like
oh no it's definitely we've had a few
setbacks what everything's gonna be all
right okay merica
are you okay oh okay now we're gonna let
it cool and then we're gonna decorate
you may notice that we are on the floor
yes but I have wax paper down and it is
a freshly cleaned floor look at that
light legs off this I'm just gonna
lightly dump no yeah I wouldn't break
that glass pane wow you're angling it
down really am i oh my gosh
okay bottom bottom is whirl
yeah hmm wait I want you to cut that
innocent tails know if we need three
we're not getting rock and be able to
get three but the cake something I look
great it's gonna be the best American
cake you can get this isn't right well
no kidding I think I'm becoming a
diabetic just like looking at this case
I ate half the icing I'm I'm literally
disgusted oh nice I'm starting at the
bottom because I can start at the bottom
now we're here started from the bottom
now my whole cake - yeah
give me the plate I'm trying okay all
right okay oh it's so what we're gonna
do let's have a pancake you should've
spent pancakes then they're going on all
right what I'm gonna do I just
this is way too much icing look we have
to just put a little bit because it just
has to seal it together I didn't know oh
now I know shave off this topic okay I'm
just gonna shave this up that was
America I would be like I'm not down
with us we need to make this around
circle huh over here tells heavy
it's actually really heavy and I'm not
sure that's gonna be very good for I
think you should um hold on he's watch
this that wasn't the problem
what was the problem no I've actually
they're mine now hopefully this will
pull it out she's great look okay have
to ice the inside of this actually may
you don't hold on a second red cake blue
cake white cake icing cake okay this is
just like honestly honestly Martha
Stewart is somewhere watching this video
crying saying Wow Wow girls girls girls
crowd in are the cake in Polly's
the problem here is the blue should've
shaved a little bit off the wall
mmm it's okay yeah let's get that right
fill in these crevices I'm like I'm so
sick just looking at this it's all going
to look perfect when we cut the cake in
half
don't need it here we need another one
we need to put to it we knew what the
problem is but there's a few problems
here the other is second okay oh my gosh
okay
it's almost like a little cake like look
you can actually almost trick somebody
into thinking like I can sell this at a
bakery for prime prices how much
probably like $14 $14 said it cost us a
lot more than $14 in there we can make
you want to go on I don't think we can
no actually oh here comes sorry oh this
doesn't mean that what American okay the
last thing we're gonna do for our cake
since it's so beautiful is I'm gonna set
a couple I don't know where that tip one
it probably went in the cake
so either way let's just add this little
bit of we just want to decorate the bit
of our cake with some red I'm some blue
by me just to make it look like a little
fireworks
okay ready it will just add a little bit
of red there nice in here no the real
test is cutting it in half if I stand
all the way back here the cake looks
really good
[Music]
there we go it's gonna look just like it
did on Pinterest
yeah I'm alright
oh okay just set it somewhere there it
is so my last camera been destroyed no
we were so new I can't get in the lens
good my other one got destroyed okay
it's not the microphone are you kidding
me oh my god I hate came out perfectly
it's really sad me too haha nicee do we
use probably everyone do this I want
this cake to be perfect I thought I
honestly thought we could do this really
above looks may be deceiving kids I lost
my phone I can eat this whole thing
I'm sigh I feel good I think I might
have baked my phone inside of this well
thanks for watching we know how to clean
up now I think we might need to hire
some like it hazmat cam I'm disgusted
[Music]